I would now like to calculate the
potential function for two other
conservative forces that we encounter
all the time spring forces and
gravitational forces will begin with
spring forces so first off let's begin
with some type of coordinate system
suppose we have a spring we have a block
this is my point X equal equal Ibrahim
unstretched length of the spring and now
whether we stretch it or compress it
here I'll stretch it I'll introduce a
coordinate function X unit vector I and
my spring force F is minus KX I where X
can be positive for a stretched spring
forces and then a negative I hat
direction when X is negative negative
times negative means the spring force is
in the positive I hat direction when
it's compressed so this is a force
that's a restoring force always back to
equilibrium this is a example of a
conservative force and now let's
calculate the change in potential energy
and then introduce a zero reference
point and get a potential function for
this force so the first calculation is
straightforward so if we took our
displacement to be DX I had and we take
the dot product of F n yes we get DX I
had that I had as 1 times DX and that's
just the X component of the force
displacement my and minus sign because
the X component of the force is negative
K X and so now if we were to start our
system so again for our initial state
let's say that the block from the
unstretched position as is stretched X I
and our final state whether it's
stretched or compressed it won't matter
but we'll just stretch it out a little
bit more 2x final so now let's calculate
the change in potential energy between
our initial and our final States
now recall there's a minus sign because
it's minus W conservative that's minus
the integral X initial 2x final of minus
K X DX we have two minus signs
that's our integration variable if you
want to see it in all the detail and
when you simply integrate X prime DX
Prime you get X prime squared over two
and so the change in potential energy
between these two states is one-half K X
final squared minus one-half K X initial
squared and that's physically meaningful
if I take my system initially and I the
system ends up in the final state then
what I'm calculating is minus the work
done by the spring force on the block as
it goes from the initial state to the
final state I'm not talking about the
work that an external agent does and
stretching and or compressing it this is
explicitly the work done by the spring
force on the block as it goes from the
initial state to the final state I
introduced the minus sign and our
definition of potential energy and so
this quantity represents the negative of
the work done by the spring force as the
system goes from the initial to the
final states now you may have already
thought about it but the reference point
that we're going to use is x equals 0
the unstretched length of the spring and
our reference potential at that point
will be 0 so our reference point is
actually the zero point for the
potential and then our arbitrary state
we can call this the reference state if
you like that's probably better than the
reference point our arbitrary state will
be at some arbitrary stretch or compress
and our potential energy function at
that reference minus
the potential energy at the arbitrary
state - the reference state well if we
set X I equal to 0 and X final equal to
X as we have in this expression we
simply get 1/2 K x squared so the
potential energy function equals our
reference potential plus 1/2 K x squared
and we've defined that our reference
potential to be 0 it could have been
anything but we're making it 0 so that
we get a nice function 1/2 K x squared
and again it's always worthwhile to plot
that function it's a nice parabola U of
X X and you can see down here that's our
reference point